hello everyone and welcome to the
highlight show of class chess
international my name is Seth of Abraham
Ian and I'm going to take you to the key
moments of day seven today was also day
one of the final so after six days of
very exciting matches will finally have
Magnus Carlsen and Fabiana call or
Caruana
facing off in the finals the world
numbered one against the world number
two this great rivalry that they have
going since their World Championship
match so of course this is a match that
everyone was looking forward to the big
faceoff and it really lived up to all
the hype so today's games were really
amazing some high quality games many ups
and downs some really exciting moments
and what a thriller it was somewhat
spoil it for you what happened
and so we'll come round by round and I
will tell you exactly what happened so
with that said let's jump right into the
action so let's start with the first
game so Magnus Carlsen starts with the
English and the reason I'm showing you
the opening is because something very
interesting happened on move seven so
we're at most six for black so if I gave
you this position and asked you to guess
what would white play in this position I
don't think anyone would be able to
guess the move so White's move was king
f2 and I'm not really sure what to say
about this move but you know this Magnus
played it then we should we should all
agree that this is a playable so Fabiano
continuously six logical move so we're
still in the opening phase of the game
so again I'm not going to comment on
every single move we're just going to
reach the key moment so players still
developing Magnus did get a big edge in
this position and I will point out one
so his position is already improving
rooks coming into play a king goes back
doesn't need to be NFC anymore so this
is what we call castle by hand and
instead of counseling you play like King
F to rook e1 King goes to Jiwon takes
three moves but gets the job done
doubling the rooks on the e-file I
really like how mangoes places that
simply move by move improving his
position I love this Queen only for this
knight on d5 expanding on the Kings side
where he has the pawn majority
slow improvements exchanging the Quinns
entering an endgame and this is where
magnet and this is where Fabiano made an
error he played rook g8 instead he needs
to play d3 which looks like a bad move
because King comes and gets the pawn but
there is this amazing resource of night
before the point is you cannot take my
knight because after d2 who is stopping
this pawn so this would be very
unfortunate
so instead Tariq needs to swing to one
to the side of the board let's say here
check and all these pawns are getting
going to get exchanged so the King has
to go back to stop this pawn I will take
your f 5 pawn you look after my a pawn
and everything will get exchanged and we
will make will shake hands but this did
not happen so Fabiano goes rook g8 and
finds himself in some hot water Ciroc h6
so there's another key moment that we're
going to reach in this game there's
still a lot of adventures so decides to
push the pawn so now Magnus is up a pawn
but then for some reason he plundered or
miscalculated so instead of defending
this pawn on c4 with a move like root
before he decides to go ping g5 and
after check he just simply lost upon and
now there's just nothing to play for so
I will just take you to the end of the
game so basically they exchange
everything here so there's no need for
me to do any conga to make any comments
so literally everything is coming off
the board
I mean were already here so let's see
what happened ok so now they just repeat
so in the postgame interview Bobby said
that he was likely to escape with a draw
and he was because objectively he was in
a very tough position and Magnus you
know could have nursed that to nurse
that advantage and won the game and this
is something that Magnus is very good at
doing so let's jump to our second gamer
Fabiana has the white pieces so this was
a royal
so in this position Fabiano decides to
go for the endgame and Magnus easily
neutralizes the position and pieces come
off so I'm not really going to focus on
this game because it's quite a long game
but there isn't a lot of action they
basically exchange everything so I was
looking at it with an engine and I'm not
sure why I actually engine really
prefers Quincy too and gives white a big
edge I think maybe it's because of poor
pawn structure and and this Knight
center but I think there's a lot of
fight left in the opening in the
position and but I do think this was
maybe better try for white to go for and
try to play for the advantage here
instead he exchanges Queens d5 and a lot
of exchanges so we'll see all these
pieces start coming up soon so again
this game losses for another 30
something moves and we don't need to
look at it so let's jump to our third
game which was the most exciting game
round okay I shouldn't say it was the
most exciting but it was the start of
the most at the excitement on move 25 we
did see an amazing move which just
destroys blacks position entirely so
blacks last move was to go Queen seed
getting out of ping makes sense and now
comes a5 amazing move just crushes the
position again this concept of attacking
on the most offended square so you know
f5 is defended by two pawns so when a
square is defended by two pawns you just
think nothing can happen there because
it's such a secure square but turns out
that there is no good way of reacting to
this move so he played she takes a five
and actually it's funny because it takes
a five just puts up no resistance
because after take take 25 everyone is
hanging Knight is hanging pawn is
hanging it's actually impossible to
different the Knights of the knight has
to move but the knight doesn't have a
square to go to it cannot go to the
eight rookies hanging if you go here I'm
gonna take and the rook is hanging again
so already the position is just
reasonable so instead Fabiano tries to
put up a fight so it takes with the pawn
cannot call this sacrifice in exchange
takes on age five not threatening maiden
of seven and eight seven
so defense and we see or maybe we don't
see but now we see that the panel Jeter
is hanging and maybe natural move that
occurs to you is to play King G to
balance that Magnus decides I don't need
this fun who just takes on d5 which is
such a remarkable move because you're
hanging upon next to your king with a
check and it just looks so scary just
you know if you don't really dig deep it
feels like immediately you should
dismiss it takes e5 and immediately try
to defend that pawn well let's take a
look at what happens so if Queen g3 the
King goes here and now with threatening
made again so now the Queen has to go
back and now there is actually very
pretty line in this position so there
are a lot of ways for white to player of
course but let's take a look at this one
so queen h7 check in eight six so if the
King goes to G a troop g1 is coming with
all kinds of mates if King runs a six
pawn is falling so Bishop g7 looks like
the logical move and check out this
really pretty line nine eight seven
negative six cannot take because mate so
King has to go to f8 now Queen g7 cannot
take I guess no other good option but if
you take 98 and everyone hangs what a
way to finish the game huh
unfortunately this didn't happen but the
way the game ended was also very nice so
C takes d5 so far beyond of course
decides that's not to go for this kind
of misadventure so it goes rookie seven
objectively the position is just lost so
takes only six
since the bishop check just comes back
and no way to defend the piece so he
resigns so a really unfortunate way for
Fabiana to start this match with a loss
in round three so there was one more
game to go before the clutch game so of
course it's a very tough situation to
being playing Magnus Carlsen when you're
behind people when you know you're
trailing him because once it gets the
advantage it doesn't really let go so
let's start with this position so if we
take a look this position is just
absolutely crazy King is not see King is
not safe
like slice move was a five weakening the
King given more so Fabiano goes 27 which
to me kind of was kind of a weird move
because where is the Queen going feels
like the Queen should stay on this side
as the bishop where the bishop wants to
go so the bishop doesn't necessarily
wants to go to c5 because that's where
the knight wants to go so he put the
bishop here and then your knight cannot
move so maybe the bishop has to go back
but now white can think about moving the
knight to d2 or e1 and bringing the
Queen to h3 and the pawn structure is
ugly for everyone if we look cannot
pinpoint to a healthy pawn in this
position so everything is just hanging
everything is loose but I don't see how
black is gonna go after this King but
this kink on the other hand looks very
unsafe to me so I would say white is
doing really well here so Queen e7 so
rook the 8v8 so we're going to enter an
endgame so a lot of exchanges are
happening so what is up upon but as I
mentioned this pawn structure is just
hideous and you do have this CC pawn so
because they're all isolated it's almost
like you're not up upon but of course we
don't really think of it that way
because in any kind of King component
game this would be very relevant
don't mind is still up upon not the best
fun but upon is upon so pushes the pond
so we see more exchanges so looking at
this position looks like we're entering
the draw territory but again op upon can
keep playing forever so then that goes
there and we see this king do six very
strange move looks logical but
unfortunately it runs into very simple
tactic and the reason I say strange move
is because we're not really used to
seeing Magnus blunder this kind of
tactics and now the knight on g4 is
hanging and black immediately finds
himself in a lost end game and resigns
very few moves later so let's check it
out a3 stopping the King from entering
if you remember yesterday's game of
Levon Aronian vs. Magnus Carlsen where
Magnus give up the exchange and the King
ran to the Queen side and took
everything basically you know remember
that game don't let the king in slides
over the King gets cut off
and you just push the pawn it's nothing
to do and the game ended here white wins
and in the view of it's just impossible
to stop this one the King can go okay
let's make a few moves for example here
and hopefully you know this little trick
so you check and put a rope behind upon
and now you're just going to be up at
least rook who most likely a queen so
now the majesty to talk about the clutch
game so this is not the clutch game but
still a clutch victory right you're down
a point trailing Magnus and then you win
the very next game and now the magicite
so now we're entering the clutch game so
if it's your first time watching this
the clutch games are the games that are
worth more points so because this is the
first day the clutch games are worth 2
points so let's jump to move to any
month so this was a remarkable game and
really heartbreaking what happened so of
course already you can see that Magnus
one because it says 1-0 on your screen
but let's take a look through the game
so root D form of course very logical
move attacking this g7 pawn
and we would think that Fabiana would
play of six but he plays this 94 witches
such a stunning move to understand this
game the position so deeply giving up
this pawn centralizing the Queen
threatening to go rookie to and
basically saying you're okay silly is
just trapped so Magnus goes after him
rook comes here who comes into the game
and again
it looks very scary because it looks
like this rope and the Queen are
attacking but in fact the queen is just
tied down to the rook and the rook is
not really doing much on g7 because of
the placement on f5 Queen so some checks
trade so we entered this route excuse me
this Queen endgame so now they're just
moving trying to create something so now
we're going to see another key moment
here and a little bit heartbreaking how
this game ended so check and a5 and tier
Fabiano made this crucial mistake of
taking instead he should play something
like Queen a for keeping an eye out on
this pawn because you know this Queen is
a little bit tied down defending this
pawn if you put a coin up and therefore
you're asking your opponent how you're
defending the d4 pawn and so posing some
problems instead he took and now Magnus
just collect all this pawn so King runs
back and now C 4 and C 4 is a very nice
move and you cannot take because this
end game is just lost with this to pass
pawns
no one is stopping them it's just not on
time to stop this pawn so you go here I
push your King gets distracting the
other Punk win so it's just impossible
you can't King cannot stop pawn so far
away from each other okay so let's go
back to the game so he plays after c4 he
plays queen g4 pushes his pawn
so okay well I can still fight by going
back with the king but you know when it
rains its poor it Forest King g5 trading
down into a lost and game by a temple it
resides here in view of f2 and c8 Queen
of course this is just game over it
doesn't matter that you have a bishop on
because there's so many other punts on
the board so very difficult last for a
Fabiano Khurana losing the clutch game
and falling two points behind Magnus
Carlsen and now we have one more game
left in the in the day so let's take a
look at this game so this was another
crazy position so if you remember the
other game with some game - this should
be the reminiscent of that game so p3
was plate she takes c3 d5 and Hannah
castle not taking back I'm trying to
open up the D file and basically saying
you're d3 pawn is mine so rooks Eamon
was played as a Fabiana decides to give
up the exchange 95 and f6 and this is
the moment where everything turns out
and take the table strength because in
the postgame interview Magnus said that
he did not predict this movie didn't see
coming and he just didn't react well to
it and here he just blunders basically
and things really started to fall apart
for him
so he goes we should be five a four so
now the night comes here takes 95 and
his 95 is a really nice move cannot
touch the night there goes the Queen and
now this is six pawn is nothing - well
Bishop is ready to join the attack and
White's King is a lot safer than this
guy
so Queen b7 was plate takes so I took so
Fabiana and after postgame interview
admitted that it was difficult to win
this position when we look at it it
doesn't look that difficult but I guess
when he was playing it he felt maybe
he's letting it go or you know he felt
this pressure this resistance from
Magnus but I think this happens a lot
when we look at a game and it's you know
this top players play they make it look
so easy but we don't understand like a
real struggle that goes behind it so
Quinn goes back and wide it starts
collecting everything so now we're going
to enter an endgame Trading the coins
and let's check out this technique by
Fabiana Khurana he played very precise
here the King comes mean so worth
mentioning that at no point can you take
this guy because the pump runs so you
have to stay in the square h5 king h4
and Bishop d6 and the bishop do just
defense everything and this is why
bishops are so good when there is action
on both sides of the board because they
can defend both sides and the Knights
can become pretty useless and he goes
here and magnus carlsen resigns because
if you take there's no stopping the pawn
otherwise I'm going to take this f5 pawn
and I'm going to have once again have
passed pawns on both sides of the board
and you just cannot deal with that and
with this now the match is tight for
four and talk about a clutch victory by
man Oh Karl Fabiana Caruana twice coming
back from a loss to win the very next
game and what a thriller it was to watch
this game the commentators were going
crazy like the excitement was through
the roof what a match in the postgame
interview Fabiana said it was a
difficult day for him and you know and
then he said what more could you ask for
you know like who would have guessed
some who would have expected so many
decided the size of games and madness
was quite upset because he felt he could
have won this game and he was doing
really well in this game but he was
still feeling very confident because he
thinks he's the
player and he feels that he played
better than his opponent so he feels
very disappointed that this better play
didn't yield more results for him so
thank everyone for watching tomorrow is
going to be the final game of this
tournament so and the next six games
between these two players are going to
be played tomorrow and the champion is
going to be crowned so please make sure
you're tuning in you can watch the
coverage with yes I Sarah and Jennifer
Shahade en mer is Ashley on our YouTube
channel or you can check it out on us
just gems you can also look through all
the games at your own pace or analyze
them on either leeches or on us just
gems